framework or hypothesis testing by
dimension hi everyone thanks for coming
and thanks the organizer for a wonderful
workshop so today I'm gonna talk about a
general framework for hypothesis testing
in high dimension and this is based on
joint work with my colleague Jason Lee
at USC so let me start suppose that you
are getting n data points so those are
y1 x1 2 y and x and y is just a response
variable on sample I and X I is the
covariant vector or the feature vector
of that sample and one of the main tasks
in statistical learning is to try to fit
a model to this data and confining
ourselves to the parametric model this
means that you assume that Y I generated
according to this probabilistic model
that is from tried by theta 0 let's say
theta 0 is in P dimension and you want
to estimate the stator and the jet
coordinate somehow quantified the
contribution of feature of rej and the
response by it so in this talk I will
focus on the high dimensional settings
so the number of samples and is much
smaller than the number of dimensions P
and we assume that theta 0 is mostly
sports so it has only s nonzero
coordinates
to make our life easier let's focus on
the linear model so in this case y is
given by x theta zero plus some random
noise and I'm assuming W to be normal
but you can relax this assumption and
one of the prominent approach to
estimate theta zero in this case is the
last estimator that I think everyone
knows it tries to optimize discussed
function that somehow promotes this var
solution through this l1 penalization
now there's a great little literature on
less soup in the past two or three
decades especially in terms of the point
estimation you have different types of
guarantee under different assumptions in
terms of parameter estimation variable
selection prediction and also there are
various fast implementation of the lasso
and it has been widely using different
domains of application
thanks to these great researchers and
many others that are still contributing
so in this fact I want to go on behind
the point estimation and I want to talk
about the statistical inference on the
model from suit so to be specific I
would like to develop a general
framework for doing this sort of
hypothesis testing so the null
hypothesis is that your parameter theta
0 belongs to some set Omega and the
alternative is just the opposite of that
one and this Omega is some pre given set
to you now you can think of encoding
different types of the structure in the
set Omega and then if you have this
framework you can test whether your
theta 0 has that type of structure or
not and we are not making any
restricting assumption and Omega so it
could be non convex or even disconnect
and before I proceed I wanted to mention
that there is a paper by Yin Xiu in
Yelena that started the same problem but
the methodology and also type of results
are different but I wanted to highlight
this one so let me continue by some
specific example of this set Omega so
the first example is when you want to
test one specific prompter in your model
so you want to test with your theta 0 I
theta 0 is 0 versus the alternate
and being left I gave a very good
example yesterday
that you had some pricing model and you
want to see what's the elasticity you
want to see what's the effect of price
on the demand so that corresponds to low
for instance doing inference on one
coordinate and in this case you can take
omega to be all the vectorizing RP that
vanishes on the ice court and this has
been a long the problem that have been
studied in the past couple years and
using the duality of confidence interval
and hypothesis testing also if you use
your frame where you can get valid
confidence interval for theta the second
example is if you want to do inference
on the quadratic film so let's say Q is
some given metrics to you and you want
to test whether the norm of Q theta 0 is
in some interval this problem is itself
very interesting because okay if you
take Q equal identity you can do
inference on the size of of the signal
and in this paper by Lucas Rina and
Emmanuel it's argued that if you can do
inference on the size of the theta you
can also do inference of D and on the
error of your estimator so the idea here
is to do data splitting so you split
your data into two chunks
y1 x1 and y2 x2 you try just mature
that's a lesser estimator using the
first chunk so you get some theta at 1
now if you define Y tilde to be Y 1
minus x1 1 this also corresponds to a
plug in for y1 so it's X theta 0 minus
theta hat 1 plus 9
now this is your new signal so if you
have some framework to do inference on
and the size of the signal this also
lets you to do inference on the air
to oddity but the artists are if you if
you have a framework to do hypothesis
passing this automatically gives you a
framework to do to make confidence
interval so that would be the interval
of all the values that you fail to
reject it's just some relationship
between these two so this is sort of
granted
the second example is say you have
random design so they are coming from
some distribution with population Sigma
now if you take u to be Sigma half then
you can use this framework to do
inference on the proportion of explained
by H so that's the ratio of the strength
or variation explained by the signal to
the variation in your response so you
can show that this this quantity in the
denominator concentrates very well it's
a chi-square with n degree of freedom so
if you can do inference on this one you
can also do inference on the explained
variation and this is useful for
instance in G was genome-wide
Association study because it tells you
what fraction of variation in the trait
can be explained by genes rather than
the the environment
the third example is okay
there are many results for support
recovery of lassu but mostly they
require condition called theta min
condition so you want the minimum
nonzero theta to be above some threshold
if you have Gaussian design and under
some assumption then you can remove s
here now although this assumption is
commonplace in the theory it's hard to
verify that in practice because you
don't know what stays at zero now in
this case again you can take Omega to be
this family of vectors and you can test
whether theta 0 blinds to this set or
not
the fourth example is if you want to
test over the convex cone so this is a
problem that naturally arises in
studying the treatment effect so these
are two important example one is the
non-negative cone so let's say theta I
is the effective treatment I and you
want to see whether all the treatment
that you have in your study are harmless
so you want to test with our theta
edging non negative code or let's say
different treatment corresponds the
different dosage of the drug and it's
plausible to assume that if the Dragons
have any effect then its effect should
be monotone in the dosage that you are
using so you can test whether they tied
in monotone cone and there is a long
history of work on this problem then
Gaussian sequence model from 63 to okay
and the last example is you can use this
framework to test arbitrary function of
theta so you can take any function f
from Rp to R and this would be your
Omega and then you can also compute
confidence interval for f of theta 0 so
in particular interested when you take f
of theta to be a linear function so you
can compute the confidence interval for
the predictions I hope that you are
convinced that it's an interesting
problem and useful so this is the
outline for the remaining yes oh my god
no
that's not adaptive well if you do
suppose spitting you can do
let me get random with your framework
yeah I think by random means that the
Omega depends on Y and X right yeah so
I'm sorry the methodologies have
different steps I go through them one by
one
the first one is try to look at the
problem instead of working with the
original problem I want to work with a
projected version of the problem so this
is the null hypothesis that they have
instead of trying to test this
hypothesis I project on some sub size
subspace you this is what they do now
it's easy to see that if this null
hypothesis is true then the H tilde is
also true if something is in Omega then
the projection about genome X so if I
can control the type 1 error the false
positive rate for this one it also
controls the false positive for the
first problem but you might lose power
if you don't use you wisely enough
because it might be the case that theta
0 is not in the Omega but when you
project it's inside yo mega so you might
lose power here but let's say you do
some some good you for the moment so now
you have the problem in K dimension if u
is just the basis of that space in K
dimensional the second step is
on the second step is doing D biasing
but in a rotated basis so let me give
you some background and D biasing
so the last estimator is very good in
terms of the point of summation it gives
you a good estimation error and also the
prediction error but something that's
not so good is that expired because of
this l1 penalty and in particular it's
hard to characterize the distribution of
lassoo in high dimension for general
design X now the idea of D biasing was
to start from the last two estimator and
try to remove the bias as much as you
can and then this gives you another
estimator called the D bias estimator
that it had less bias but also it goes
under some distributional
characterization I'm doing the biasing
on a rotated space so if you look at
theta 0 in the projected space these are
the coordinates of the vector but this
is gamma 0 and I want to do D bias aim
directly on gamma 0 so this is the form
of a D biased estimator it had u
transpose theta hat and then you have
this X structure I need to define G so I
will see that in a moment but this is
the general form that you by adding this
term I'm trying to remove the by
yourself u transpose theta now if you
take you to be identity this becomes the
classical D biasing that have been
studied in past couple years so what i'm
doing here is different from computing
the classical d biasing and then
projecting that that doesn't work here
i'm directly trying to devise you
transfer tape and if you take you to be
a vector than this becomes the proposal
that was offered by tony and region 2070
so here u is just some metric I did we
choose G so let's try to play with this
device estimator a little bit by
plugging for y so Y is X beta 0 plus W
and then I rearrange the terms and write
in terms of the empirical covariance
Sigma
so you get a bias term here and this is
your Gaussian error provided that G is
independent of W which is independent of
W conditioning on X this becomes the
Gaussian random so what's a good device
estimator ideally I want to kill the
bias and I want to make the variance as
a small as possible let this gives you
some idea of how you should choose G so
if you look at the I squared unit of the
bias you can bound it this way so it's
the L infinity l1 norm and the variance
of the divisor Scimitar is given by this
function so both of them depends on G GI
the right column of G so I want to
choose GI in a way that minimizes both
of them so we do that with this
quadratic optimization so you want to
minimize the variance and you have some
constraint on the bodies so me here is
some tuning parameter so it's somehow
played a trade-off between the bias and
variance here here you are trying to
control the bias and you are trying to
minimize the right at the same now the
theorem is that if f log p over root n
goes to 0 then this is a devious
estimator of u transpose theta G gamma D
- your signal is given by some Gaussian
noise you know exactly what the
distribution is the covariances and
those are the bias term vanishes
asymptotically in infinity now i know
thats are some people who doesn't like
this assumption so you can relax this at
least for the gaussian so you can make s
log P over N goes to 0 and get the same
thing for the Gaussian design but for
general randoms design or fixed design I
don't know how to X here ok so I
simplify too much so you can sum either
X which sub Gaussian rows and the
population covariance should have banded
I can values and if you want to take the
fixed design then you want the coherence
number
positive and that dictates how you
should choose new here huge me with
children depending on the incoherence
number of the design so this
accommodates fixed decisis yep so if we
go to the result the your cyber so when
when I have things going to infinity
what happens to a fixed design when I go
to infinity so universe let's go to your
result perhaps yeah so there's something
I understand thank you for this as a as
a rockets we use little more notation so
it's an asymptotic result right yeah so
what does this mean when I have a fixed
design so it means that if you condition
V on X is given by normal distribution I
need to know what X is right when when
the size of the problem gets large yep
and we get some probabilistic pondan
Delta infinity bigger than
you start I think I understand the
statement of every though I think is
what I think about the problems doing
large sizes going to infinity which i
think is a result to you ha ha ha how do
i how does this fit was a fixed design
what fixed is you mean oh ok somehow it
is a deterministic sequence ok so the
way that we do for the fixed design is
not in that some part so you get the
probabilistic bound that if you have a
design with N and P what's the
probability that this one is bigger than
sorry for simplifying to one
okay okay thank you so that was the
second step that you did you do bias
your estimator and now the third step is
okay this is the D biased estimator this
is your true signal this is the noise
and this is the buyer
let's manage it that's emphatically so
what they do is that I do an L infinity
projection of the device estimator on
the set Omega but this is so this matrix
C here is just chosen to make this Z to
be normal standard normal on each
coordinate so it has correlated
coordinate but I want each coordinate to
be the standard normal but this is just
some diagonal metrics to normalize thing
and then I do some infinity projection
and then the tester statistics is the
value of this optimization
and you can think you can see why I'm
using the hell infinity because they can
control the bias in the L infinity norm
and then this becomes if theta if the
null hypothesis is true this is our
syntactically dominated by the infinity
norm of Z and this is the Tessa
statistics that you that you use and
then the fourth step is just to do the
decision rule so you take the test of
statistics and you compare it with the
threshold and Z alpha is just the
quantile of the standard mode
but I want to summarize so this is
mostly the decision I need to modify it
a little bit because I've not told you
yet how to choose you but if you know
what's the good you then this is the
procedure that you follow you project
the problem and subspace u UD by us your
transpose theta hat you do L infinity
projection on Omega zero this is your
test statistic and then you have the
decision is to our first three steps any
question so what is the is just a
diagonal matrix to make the covariance
one on the on the diagonal so marginally
yeah marginally same yeah
no it's bounded by some known yeah so
you need to argue that if theta zero is
in the set Omega then the objective is
less than when you plug in theta
barriers
so what's the theory that we have so
let's say you want to get the more
important things than to control the
false positive rate so I define the
false positive rate in the following
thing so it's a probability of rejection
if the null hypothesis is true and then
I take the supremum over all the theta
in set Omega that are SS worse and as to
the function of N and you are thinking
as in particle
this is the theorem for random design
well it has I think the assumption that
we need the design has subduction pros
and X Sigma inverse for X Sigma inverse
a sub cache and Rho and Sigma is bounded
eigenvalue now in this theorem I'm
assuming you to be any arbitrary fix you
that's unitary so this is the basis of
some subspace K dimensional sub 3 and
it's independent of your samples so any
you that is independent of this one
satisfy the assumptions of the theorem
and you can control the false positive
rate this holds for almost any
and you can come up with some analogous
result for the deterministic sign just
skipping back
now the question is how to choose you so
that's the more interesting part so if I
want to see what's the good trace of you
I need to analyze the power and then
choose the you that maximizes that power
so this is the measure of the
alternative strength that I define if
I'm a quantified what's the distance of
theta from the set Omega you transferred
here if there was no you transferred for
just the distance of theta 0 to the set
Omega so you want to see how far your
true signal is from the null hypothesis
set and then you can quantify the power
of of this test so it's given by some
function f it has three arguments the
first one is alpha this is the level of
false positive rate that you have the
last one is K is the dimension of the
space you it's this way dimension of the
space that you are basically doing your
test and then here this is the
signal-to-noise ratio basically so after
here is the strength of the alternative
and this is the function given for the
power
that's what the expression might look
strange but let's see how it looks on
the plot so I'm plotting this F of Alpha
X by fixing alpha and then I'm changing
X so there are two property that you
should know the first thing is that if
you increase X so if the signal is
getting stronger then the power goes up
so this is what you expect and the other
one is that it's monotone decreasing in
K so if I increase K the plot goes down
for for a fix X this is the these are
two properties of this function that
they want you now the choice of the
spaces you would be basically I want to
optimize this power over a K so k could
be any number between 1 and P and U is
any basis for the K dimensional space
saying that it's a basis and I want to
optimize this one now can you optimize
this
okay the first problem is that I don't
know what state of zero like I want to
go about this problem the easy way is to
okay ie I use last thing instead of
fatal year I replace this my state I had
but this gives me another problem
because I wanted you to be independent
of Y I and X I so if I use the lasso
Scimitar here then the you that they
obtain depends on theta hat and depend
on the days how do I solve this or you
already mentioned that you can do data
split so what I do is that I take my
data I split it into two half I use the
first one to get eight at one and then I
plug in theta at one here instead of
theta 0 and optimize to get you and then
I use you and the second half to form
the device estimator for that should be
u transpose data do this is basically
what we did these are splitting once
plated used to optimize and find you and
then you will use with the second half
to to form the device
there might be some ways if you use our
Charter and other system maybe you can
avoid the data splitting you're not
smart enough to to do that so this
becomes a problem that you have if the
data at one and I want to optimize so
this is an optimization problem but in
principle you should be able to solve it
but let me mention one case that if
Omega is convex then this becomes super
easy why it's super easy when Omega is
combats you can argue that the maximum
of this cost function is achieved for k
equal 1
but there is one so you need to take K 1
and then there is one specific direction
that maximizes this power so what's the
idea here that if you look at this this
was the strength of the alternative the
distance of theta hat 1 from the set
Omega so you can write it in terms of
min max and then if Omega is coming back
you can use the 1-year max min max
theorem and so have this mean and Max
and then you can show that for any youth
there is one vector u such that this
holds true there is one u such that if
you take the vector little you instead
of the displace you then D this is that
will leave
now use the properties of the function f
so it was monitoring increasing in the
second argument so I replace the second
argument with this one should be here
and then I use the second property that
this is decreasing in K sorry for they
replace K with one and I get this one so
I need to optimize this dysfunction so I
can sum K is equal 1 and U is just some
vector U and you can indeed solve this
it's at the close for and the closed
form is given by this one
so what's P of Omega it's just the
orthogonal projection on the set Omega
and
you know - we do what he is an Omega
rejection and then the orthogonal
projection is just theta minus the
projection over Vega and then you just
normalize it because that what's the
direction of the vector they have the
closed form for the combat is Omega
but for the non convex America there is
no clothes for you need to do that
case-by-case so for instance key in the
case of testing the state amine
condition your Omega is non convex it's
even disconnected but we are able to see
what's the solution for for that case
but there is no closed form for any non
convex to make algebra you only consider
those sparse Venus power why don't you
just respect yourself into that's at
this one
because you already have the actual
restriction that's I think that wouldn't
change the argument here because you are
replacing theta zero by think that one
and both of them are sports doesn't
change the argument but I not sure if I
need to look up the details that you
don't remember the power is defined over
the sparse signal or okay so that would
be a relaxation of that
if we go to the examples the first
example is if you want to do linear
functional so your Omega is V transpose
theta equals to some given constant C
then in this case U is just given the
vector V it's the new covariates vector
that you have and you can show that this
gives you the minimax optimal so this
recovers the proposal by Toni and region
for prediction if you consider the
quadratic form then this becomes theta
hat one so you need to do D biasing but
in in the direction of the less so you
have y equal X theta zero plus noise and
for Sigma I'm using this type of Sigma
IJ is just Rho to the I minus J for it's
decaying at I and J coming far and then
I choose as uniformly at random from 1
to P besides it at 0 then if you are in
the set it should be B when you are in
the support and it's 0 otherwise
now this one is when you want to do when
you when you use this framework to do
hypothesis testing on the non negative
cone so when I take P to be less than so
if I take P to be positive then this
becomes type 1 error and if I take P to
be negative then this becomes the power
if I compute the probability of
rejection in this case is just the type
1 error in this case it's just the power
so you see that it's conservative here
so it's not point zero 5 but the power
is good so if you are already like 0.4
you get power 1 and also
here lo is the correlation of the Sigma
also I had good control over different
range of them of correlation the second
example is for the beta mean condition
so this is the non convex set Omega
whether they said you can compute what's
the right to you I don't have the
formula and just like but again you see
here if you take so B is one that's the
true signal so if you take C to be less
than one just becomes a type one error
if you take C to be bigger than 1 this
becomes power and again so that's the
power is good and it's considered the
false positive rate and this is for
inference on the predictions and this is
the 95 percent confidence interval so
it's around 95% that we said and these
are the length of the confidence
interval so it scales with basically the
norm of Sigma over root n the log log
plot it's linear on that one ok any
question yes I think with this one I can
conclude the talk and I would have to
take any question
[Applause]
your samples are a pageant
sorry could you speak up if the samples
are dependent even I think the
destination part is hard to say my thing
1 or 2 paper that the point estimation
result for the Sioux for correlated
samples like in the time series and
active learning that looks something but
I'll say it's not very well understood
regarding the sample splitting the first
question is if you would not split it I
even understand assimilation to be ok
and the second question is in
assimilation still looks fine but if you
do it under a single day to sit and you
split the sound do you see all the
variation beginning on how you split the
sample ok the fact is in our experience
sometimes quite a problem so yeah and of
course in practice you have a single
dataset you spit the sample and you do
the sample bleeding a hundred times a
day you can compute your p-value so how
much first the answers the first one if
you don't do data splitting our
simulation it works I expect that there
is some sharper analysis that about that
one and the second one yes if you do
splitting you see the variation on how
usefully I think the best way is either
to do some boosting if you want to do
the data splitting but I'm hoping that
someone can prove it
so actually you can aggregate I think
again but I did you can do something
robust yeah so something similar to the
posting that you are for the p-values
but if not you're in trouble is you know
I the theory which says it's it's fine
but if you actually run of course we
don't see the assimilation because in
average yeah so but in practice he would
recommend not to split this yes I I
tried and even okay so I in real data I
take the rib of love and from your HDI R
package but it's semi real data because
I'm making noise again myself so in real
the semi real data experiment this one
it doesn't matter but they don't know
let's think again and again take it up
defenders like these stalks the dark